I look at this room I'm like man do they
really realize how young they are
because I don't think they do because
it's not the way the propaganda of age
has been sold to us over the last 100
years I don't believe that anybody
really has a good enough grasp of how
much time they actually have everybody
I'm looking at 40 more years there's
some youngster like 50 60 that is a lot
of time you know I don't think people
fight for joy and happiness enough
they're based on fear they're based on
the financial obligations the
theoretical emotional oblig ations
they've made them for themselves for
their spouses and their children and you
know I really do believe being the best
version of yourself requires a level of
strategic selfishness which is grounded
in if I'm really happy I can make
everybody I love happier and if I'm
really happy everything clicks